i'm shannon breme i'm tom chalu i'm
maria bartoramo and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday september 29 2021
i'm dave anthony there's growing concern
that disputes in congress over spending
and raising the debt limit could hurt an
already fragile recovery it's sort of
crazy to think that
congress would for the first time allow
us to default on our debt and i don't
think we will but if we did it would
tank the economy in a hurry
i'm lisa brady as thousands more
migrants head toward the u.s mexico is
now using a soccer stadium to process
migrants at its southern border what the
mexican officials here are trying to
figure out is a how to put a lid on it
and b just how many are coming
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
there is a lot of uncertainty in
washington this week including a
possible government shutdown and
disputes over raising the debt limit
treasury secretary janet yellen says
that we don't increase it by october
18th the u.s could default it would be
disastrous for the american economy for
global financial markets and for
millions of families and workers putting
at risk what she calls a fragile but
rapid recovery federal reserve chairman
jerome powell told the same senate
hearing as the economy continues to
reopen we are seeing upward pressure on
prices particularly due to supply
bottlenecks in some sectors added to all
that trillions of dollars in spending
democrats are proposing but president
biden says we talk about price tags
the it is
zero
price tag on the debt we're paying we're
going to pay for everything we spend
with proposed tax hikes on corporations
and wealthier americans which all
republicans oppose and congressman james
comer told fox this is going to lead to
higher inflation inflation is a tax on
everyone so this is the most expensive
bill in the history of the american
congress and with so much at stake we're
doing a double take giving you two
different expert views we definitely
have a lot of momentum but we hit some
speed bumps this year the delta variant
being the number one speed bump charles
payne is the host of making money on the
fox business network the supply chain
issue though probably will last longer
than even this latest round of covet and
that's been a big big problem consumer
confidence came out it was a major
disaster number one issue was delta
number two was worrying that the economy
is slowing down and number three
ironically was inflation which i think
might be the biggest issue because it
hits people right in the face whenever
they go out to the supermarket to the
grocery store or even a restaurant and
we're sort of disjointed as a nation
right now
11 million jobs open the last job
support though just 238 000 only 38 000
women wages are starting to go up even
for retail workers and restaurant
workers but there's just this weird kind
of thing and i got to be honest with you
as someone who's worked from home for
almost two years a large part of it is
just people trying to get back into the
rhythm
of going out going to work going to the
same job leaving their homes there's
some things that we've never dealt with
ever before and and those have been wild
cards as well yeah and and you talked
about the job market there are a lot of
openings but there are also a lot of uh
a lot of people who seem to need jobs
but aren't taking them i mean how do we
get
service sector
companies to be able to hire there but a
lot of them that are struggling
they are and it's going to be real hard
because
you've seen a lot of these larger
companies say okay we'll pay not just
fifteen dollars i'm saying 16
amazon advertised for 125 000 jobs they
got 1 million resumes because i guess
the starting pay was 18 bucks an hour
for the 3 000 bonus
and so i think it's going to work itself
out
people have cash you know our bank
accounts are flushed we've got 2
trillion in excess savings
and i think that gives some people the
luxury even though the unemployment
checks ran out first
almost for everyone the extra
unemployment checks i think people still
have a little bit of time
congress dealing with all these economic
issues from the debt limit to the
possible government shutdown and all of
that and then you of course have three
and a half trillion dollars of spending
on top of an infrastructure bill
how much does uncertainty in washington
affect the economy in general
right now
i think
i i think most people believe it's
kabuki theater
or you know or that the ghosts in the
machine will come down like the old
greek the plays and at the very last
minute uh rescue the damsel in distress
uh someone will have a rope in the levee
and
and lower the lower the goats down and
they'll pick her up and uh vanquish the
demons and we'll all live happily ever
author because i think we've seen this
so many times
a lot of what you talked about might be
related to the debt limit and the
government shutdown
but
three and a half to five trillion
dollars in government spending in the
infrastructure bill and what democrats
are hoping to do with the buildback
better agenda for the president how does
that change the game what does that do
to the economy
if we take it at face value
uh that it would be a the three and a
half trillion wish list goes through the
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure goes
through on top of the 1.9 trillion that
already has gone through
uh and some of the programs in there i
think i think what it does is it moves
us closer toward a european style
uh social welfare state
that puts the illness on big government
so on one side of it i think you've got
this notion that maybe we peak
designation maybe we should sort of
divvy up the spoils and move sideways
not unlike japan has done over the last
20 years and some of these european
nations even longer uh and then the
other part of the argument is that no
we've got a long way to go we're in the
midst of the fourth industrial
revolution now is the time to unleash
entrepreneurship now's the time to lower
taxes get more people in the economy get
everyone ganged up on that ladder of
success and see where we can go next
when you hear
in the discussion about the three and a
half trillion dollar bill
that
it's paid for
it's essentially funded by tax increases
you obviously focus a lot on the
business sector
how does a corporate tax hike affect
everything
it slows investment
it slows hiring
it slows innovation
it slows the overall economy
that's not what we need right now i just
think these tax hikes would be really
tough but especially especially for
small businesses
you don't sound as chipper as you
sometimes do when we talk to you you
sound a little more muted like maybe
you're a little concerned am i right or
wrong
i'm more frustrated honestly it's not
i'm still wearing the rose-colored
glasses and you know honestly i'm always
excited and i don't want to sound weird
like this but i feel good about me i
feel good about people who subscribe to
my my investment service i feel good
about people who watch my show but i do
worry you know when i see the consumer
confidence number plummeting
i do worry when i see individual
investor confidence and bullishness
plummeting i i don't want people i don't
want americans to give up on this great
thing we've done well we thank charles
as always and reminds you you can watch
his show making money with charles payne
weekdays at 2 p.m eastern on fox
business time for a second opinion on
the economy and the plans in congress
for infrastructure and three and a half
trillion dollars in other spending alec
ross is a former senior adviser to
president obama author of the book the
raging 2020s the basis of the economy
right now is actually pretty strong
unemployment is down to five point two
percent we see wages going back up and
you know who can screw this up
government can screw this up if we have
a government default if we do not get a
budget through if we don't find some
common ground between democrats and
republicans
and charter road forward where we keep
the government open
then we'll see that five percent
unemployment rate tick back up to seven
and eight percent we will see uh we will
see wages stagnate so the only entity
that can screw this up for the american
people right now is government
the debt limit issue
provided let's say we can get past the
shutdown issue the debt limit why is
this so important
well it's interesting because if we
default then what that means is people
who hold us bonds
all across the country all across the
world these are this is a lot of
middle-income families in the united
states this is every big corporation
holds american bonds technically we will
be in default
it's sort of crazy to think that
congress would for the first time allow
us to default on our debt and i don't
think we will but if we did it would
tank the economy in a hurry three and a
half trillion i mean that is such a big
number and the president insists there
is no cost to it that it's paid for
entirely that it won't add to the debt
and then republicans say well you paid
for
by people who are have higher taxes
when you hear about zero cost what's
your reaction
well look there there's no zero cost you
can't expand social welfare programs you
can't take medicare and include dental
hearing and vision you can't include
long-term care for the elderly and
disabled and you can't provide preschool
and two years of community college for
free with no cost the question is just
who pays and how it's paid for and so
what the buy administration is really
focused on here is increasing corporate
taxes and increasing taxes on the
wealthiest americans but there's no you
can't say no cost you may be raising the
revenues to pay for it but it's got a
cost what about that increase though
corporate tax rate wealthier americans
paying more
you think that's a good solid plan
for companies with over 5 million
dollars in profits
it stings for companies under 5 million
dollars it doesn't really increase their
taxes now increasing the taxes on the
wealthiest americans they're talking
about that going from 37 percent to
39.6 percent with a three percent
surcharge for people making over five
million dollars a year this is a case
where i don't squeal as much because if
you're making over five million dollars
a year i don't mind your paying three
percent more in taxes to help pay for
things like dental hearing and vision
and medicare what about the claims
that this
kind of spending would lead to inflation
which is like a tax hike on everybody on
all kinds of things we buy we already
are paying more for a lot of groceries
and a lot of things
so what's interesting about this is i
think that this 3.5 trillion dollar
economic plan will actually have less of
an impact on inflation than the
infrastructure bill because if you think
about the infrastructure bill what are
you doing that you're buying raw
materials you're buying steel you're
putting men with hard hats on the
highway so the trillion dollar
infrastructure plan will actually have
more to do with inflation than the 3.5
trillion dollar economic plan
it's been a tough two years obviously
the pandemic and trying to recover and
we're still dealing with the coronavirus
and on the inflation all these things
we've just discussed
your book the raging 2020s
what's so raging what do you see that
makes things so much better as we as we
move into the future well look i'll tell
you what we're in danger of right now is
having a decade where if we don't change
things the defining emotion will be rage
we see violent political movements
rising across the political spectrum
that would have been hard to think of 10
15 years ago and again let's not make
this about democrats or about
republicans among democrats you saw
violent protests among black lives
matter among
people on the right you saw what
happened on january 6th so what we see
is rage is becoming increasingly common
across the political spectrum in the
united states and i think for example
going back to the beginning of our
conversation what i anticipate is that
if biden can't move through
some of his economic plan
some of the political rage that we've
seen sleeping a little bit since he's
been president from the left is going to
waken up and they're going to say you
know what biden can't move our agenda
and you're going to see people back out
on the streets
so your use of the word rage is literal
not like the economy is raging you mean
people are angry
look it it has a a purposeful dual
connotation so rage can be anger
but it also can be raging like how my 18
year old son uses it raging like a great
party raging like look at ours look at
my the value of my 401k going up it
could be either
alec ross
former senior adviser to president obama
now author of the book the raging 2020s
companies countries people in the fight
for our future alec thank you very much
for joining us thank you for having me
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
president biden has taken heat from both
republicans and democrats lately on
immigration his former boss even chiming
in what happens
you know at the texas border
is a painful reminder that we don't have
this right yet former president barack
obama also telling abc's good morning
america on tuesday the idea of having
open borders is unsustainable but like
the biden administration he points to
congress for not passing reforms the
president believes that our immigration
system is incredibly broken white house
spokeswoman jensaki acknowledging a
recent surge but likening it to previous
surges in 2019 and 2014. however in july
alone there were some 200 000 encounters
by border patrol a 21-year high and over
a million people since january don't get
me wrong i feel bad for these folks
but
how do you handle a
migration like that doug baxter has
spent much of his life on the rio grande
river and says he's never seen anything
like it but the surge doesn't start at
the u.s border migrants cross other
borders to get there every single one
essentially of the 15 000 haitians last
week that ended up under that bridge in
del rio first came through this point
where we are fox news correspondent
griff jenkins is on mexico's southern
border with guatemala in the border town
of tapachula where thousands more have
already arrived the mexican officials
here confirmed this week for us that
there are currently some 10 000 haitians
alone even more when you bring in the
other migrants stuck in tapachula trying
to apply for a refugee status that would
give them the ability to move more
freely north of this city into the
interior of mexico as well as get a work
permit while they buy their time because
as we know for the majority of them if
not all of them their ultimate final
destination is the us border
now i know that some of the haitians who
had been under the bridge in del rio
texas
had already been away from haiti for in
some cases multiple years had been
living in in other countries but whether
we're talking about haiti or you
mentioned you know some coming from
ghana and ending up crossing from
guatemala into mexico um how are they
getting to that point i mean it's a long
journey to get to that point and do the
mexican officials
ask them that are they are they sort of
challenged on those issues at that
border
absolutely so where we are in tabachula
as i'm talking to you it's this expanded
refugee operations space because they're
so overwhelmed with this unprecedented
search it's a soccer stadium they had to
literally go from their
operations center which is a large
building that's been there for many
years to the entire olympic-sized soccer
stadium because so many are coming and
they are coming
largely for those that are as far as
africa or haiti they come in from south
america and many of the migrants i've
talked to talk about the treacherous
journey between colombia
to panama through what's known as the
darian gap a lawless difficult
dangerous
jungle terrain that takes four five six
days to walk through it is absolutely
littered with criminals with harsh
conditions and many of the migrants said
that they witnessed a lot of people
dying along that trip and what no one
really was paying attention to
last week when the u.n had their general
assembly was the president of panama
lawrentino cohen stood up at the u.n and
said
this is something they've never seen
before he said in january in panama he
had 800 migrants
last month he had 30 000
and so what the mexican officials here
are trying to figure out is a how to put
a lid on it and b just how many are
coming now in the case of the haitians i
like to always remind listeners that
there are some significant
things that the administration has done
that have been interpreted as a green
light that now is the time to come and
in the case of in the case of
particularly the haitians at the end of
may the administration reinstated
temporary protective status for
migrants of the country of haiti that
means that if they were to cross into
the u.s and claim asylum under protected
status they would have a better chance
of being able to stay that temporary
protected status griff just mentioned
has some important fine print that the
biden administration has been
emphasizing only haitians living in the
united states before july 29th are
eligible for temporary protected status
a message delivered by homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas in del rio
just before that encampment was rapidly
cleared last week we are very concerned
that haitians who are taking this
irregular migration path
are receiving false information that the
border is open or the temporary
protected status is available but
haitians are only part of the surge so
what's driving it are the migrants
saying they feel the administration is
welcoming them even while saying the
border is closed the driving force is of
course always
the push factor from their home
countries as the
border patrol says a push factor of
poverty crime but above all
you hear there just aren't jobs there is
no
life for them in their home countries so
they want to come to the united states
however because under this
administration they perceive
that they will have a better chance of
achieving that goal what you have are an
enormous number of people saying now is
my chance to roll the dice and if you
look at the recent situation in del rio
last week
if you take the 15 000
and we know some 2000 were deported back
to haiti
12 to 13 000 according to secretary
marcus dhs secretary
some twelve thousand thirteen thousand
were able to actually stay
while they try and and play out their
claims assuming they even go voluntarily
to the immigration office to make that
claim rather than hiding in the shadows
that's a success story and those
migrants send word back through text
messages emails phone calls on social
media that they made it and so in terms
of what's pulling people up the success
stories to see that those that went
before them were able to achieve the
ultimate goal that's only a motivation
and until what the board of echo
officials tell me until that motivation
is taken away in a significant way it's
not going to slow anytime soon
does mexico
you know
have grounds to tell people
trying to cross into mexico from
guatemala
you can't come in
um or
you know if because if the numbers in
tapachula are already so overwhelming
for that city
um you know are they trying to tell more
of them know you can't come in or if is
is it really just based on whether
they're planning to continue to go to
the us if you're not staying in mexico
okay you can go on
mexico's generosity towards migrants is
starting to slow
because they see it as a numbers thing
they don't really consider uh if you
know these migrants are going to the us
we're just going to facilitate them
along that's kind of already happening
without them saying so because for
decades they've helped slow the
migratory routes which have been flowed
for various reasons from various
countries and they know
that almost all of them have the great
dream of getting to the us but while the
us has traditionally had some form of
border enforcement mexico uh realizes
that many of them might end up
staying and trying to seek asylum in
mexico and so they want to give them the
opportunity to find some work to
contribute perhaps to where they're
trying to settle however the backlog of
processing those claims right now here
in tapachula is something we've never
seen before they've processed so far
more than 77 000 claims this year on
pace to hit more than 90 000 by the end
of september and they said compare that
to last year for the entire year
they had only some 41 000 and so it
seems that
the the numbers gain in their their
willingness to accept some of these
migrants coming is is growing thin by
the sheer fact that they can't contain
or handle this kind of volume
just one other question for you in terms
of what they do there on you know at the
mexican southern border
do we know if any of these migrants are
being cover tested or background checked
because that's something that's
certainly a concern
when they cross the u.s border
at least to you know some in congress
they are not covet testing these
migrants they're coming in such massive
numbers they have had a
government health
area for these refugee operations that
we've seen we asked them are you testing
them are you
giving them a vaccine and they said we
are just here because if someone
exhibits signs of covid or they're
feeling sick for any other reason we're
here to try and help them and that is
absolutely doing nothing to to try and
either find out how bad it is or to
do anything in terms of mitigating the
risk with with respect to
quarantine or anything of that that
matter so it is a
highly
concerning in threatening covet wrist
situation we had one moment this week
where a group of families from ghana
were
very passionately upset because they
said several members of their group
needed to go to the hospital they were
so sick but yet they weren't being
admitted to the mexican hospital for
reasons that they don't have their
registration papers and another woman
holding up her baby uh right in front of
our cameras saying my baby is sick my
baby is sick if he doesn't go to the
hospital he'll die i mean this is a
humanitarian crisis as well as
a
covet risk which starts here and travels
some thousand fifteen hundred miles to
our border ultimately and ends up being
the situation that we saw in del rio fox
news correspondent griff jenkins
uh from mexico's southern border in
tapachula thank you so much for your
time and stay safe out there
lisa thank you very much
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind with a flurry of
important votes coming up in congress
president biden and the white house have
landed on an insulting completely
ludicrous new talking point they claim
that the president's agenda and a
reconciliation bill that democrats would
like to pass in the ballpark of 3.5
trillion dollars actually costs nothing
this is flat out nuts and wrong the
white house claims it's all going to be
paid for with tax increases and other
gimmicks but nonpartisan analysts are
highly dubious as they should be and the
centrist committee for a responsible
federal budget estimates that a 3.5
trillion dollar bill would really look
more like five to five and a half
trillion dollars in real spending even
if democrats find enough tax increases
to quote pay for the full freight that
doesn't mean that it's free the money's
going out the door it is real spending
to the tune of trillions they brazenly
call that price tag zero it's a lie and
a multi-trillion dollar one at that this
is guy benson host of the guy benson
show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes